and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review Hunger
Games Catching Fire oh my god you did a
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
you see sterile name Katniss and she
survived the Hunger Games which
ironically has nothing to do with hunger
at all but she's having a hard time
getting used to the life of celebrity so
president Santa Claus it's like people
want to rebel against us because you're
so likable well what do you suppose I do
I want you to stop being likeable and be
even more likeable okay wait what Dez is
booking so Candice goes to her friend
Peter and is like I can't do this
celebrity thing I care about people too
much I don't want to be like Miley Cyrus
or Justin Timberlake who wore themselves
out what everything enter adulthood I
wanna be famous just because of a
general nice person wait are you talking
is Katniss or Jennifer Lawrence now what
does it matter people will still try to
call me fat but they're drunk and Larry
Flynt comes in and is like you need to
start convincing people that you and
Peeta are in love I don't think I can do
that I love killing animals know not
that PETA your boyfriend who the one
everybody thinks you're in love with but
can tell you're not in love with because
you're so bad at it
so that guy yeah I love him see this is
why you're so bad at that so Pete and
Katniss pick up a great idea why don't
we you marry I can't do that I'm in love
with another boy oh yeah the third guy
what do you say like that I'm really in
love with him oh yeah cuz your chemistry
is so deep we share like two minutes of
screen time together hey I saved him
from getting addicted Toki went down his
back what's his name I don't know nobody
ever remembers his name I'm just calling
him Jacob the president Santa Claus is
not happy because the couple doesn't
really look like a couple and he's like
this is the worst fake relationship
since Padme and Anakin I have no choice
but to go Chamber of Secrets on this and
recycle the first movie no Candice and
Pete are back in The Hunger Games and
this time is made even more dangerous
because dusty from twister is running it
a lot like everything spinning like a
big tornado and we can't make tornadoes
only lady okay well what else spins I
don't know what o'clock that's it we'll
turn into a giant clock and leave hands
for all the competitors oh you mean like
have every
section represented our in every hour
there's something is going to destroy
them in that section yeah but once most
of them are wiped out isn't it going to
take 12 hours to circle around and kill
them and what if they catch on to this
and try to avoid those parts on the hour
well I'm not a traitor
I never said you were I am Loki what
feeling do this time around can mr.
peanut make a bunch of alliances but I
can't figure out which ones you're
making in the end I'm gonna save you I'm
gonna save you I'm gonna show you I'm
gonna save you okay why don't we agree
if we're the last ones that will kill
each other like last time because
there's no poisonous berries this time
what poisonous berries is the only way
to kill yourself in this world
look I'm just trying my best to be in
the movie where my girlfriend doesn't
die but then this ingenious scientist
figures out a way to kill off the rest
of the people
we're gonna go Benjamin Franklin on this
shit and we're gonna have lightning
strike a tree that's gonna strike a
chord it's gonna electrocute all the
water can anything go wrong when I
suppose if somebody comes to kill me oh
look somebody's come to kill me somebody
came to kill me Oh Candice has to figure
out a way for the lightning to strike
something to blow up something because
the movie kind of forgot to have a
climax so she strapped the wire to the
arrow and shoots it up in the air mean
lightning strike wow talk about
lightning fast mid lightning strike I
mean the flash would be like girl that's
impossible
but then the entire place starts to
crumble and a giant ship comes in and
Candice is picked up by the aah and it
turns out that dusty Larry Flint and
Jacob were all on the ship and dusty is
like the revolution is happening now
this was all plan to get you out but
wasn't it your idea to put me in this
deathtrap to begin with yeah but I knew
you'd get out even though you have to
look best all the best players were in
this one yeah but I knew you'd get out
and even though only a handful of those
winners are in the revolution when you
probably could've told everybody we kind
of worked out some sort of scheme
together yeah but I knew you'd get out
and did you spin the island at some
point killing a lot of the other
contestants me very possibly mean one of
those contestants along with the killer
monkeys on the killer smoke yeah but I
knew you'd get out even though this
arrow winding thing was just
incredibly good timing and you would
have no other way to get that ship in to
pick me up
Hey look penis missing sure do Candice
finds out that her sister mother are
safe but her home is destroyed the
revolution has begun and they have to
save Peeta from Jabba the Hutt I need
evil Santa 3 so Catching Fire was a
really good movie even only kind of home
alone tune in and cutting and pasting
the script but it's like oh really happy
couple - hey
imagine Kevin fighting baboons in New
York that's what London Yorkers think
they do anyway
hey let's Hunger Games should be in New
York despite the fact that Chicago now
has the highest crime rate but hey at
least we're number one in something this
is jittery boom see shy yeah change come
on every guy oh we yes come on judge
come on I'll bring the Hunger Games to
Chicago you can have the Dark Knight
fighting to lose letters
you